Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Home Improvisation... The Sweden simulator
That's not what it is
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to home improvisation.
The IKEA simulator which is FROM Sweden!
That's what I was trying to think of.
Anyway, so you -
[fumbling over words]
- this is where you and the box and and the thing...
There's
STUFF
And then you gotta put them together
and I'm gonna...I'm gonna try not to be an idiot here
but you know how hard that is for me
and I'm gonna actually try
I dunno how to do this
No.
How'd it --
I don't wanna go online!
I don't want everyone to see my shame
Only people that subscribe to me.
*yelling* eughhhnnnaaa!!
How do I get it to go up?
Ho-
*realizes* Ahhhh
ROTATE, you bitch.
It didn't give me any tutorial about this, there's nothing to this.
How do I -
There's no control list??!!
Oh come on!
How do I -
HOW DO I FUCKING TURN YOU?
HOW THE COCK ASS
I SAID I WAS GONNA
Oh I gotta use a key p - WHAT THE FUCK?
[Screams odd sound]
HUH?
WHAT THE FUCK HAPPENED?
WHERE AM I??
I barely even star -- OH
OH
OH, IT'S A CINEMATIC VIEW
OOOOOOOH
AIN'T THAT A B-- who the fuck is --
I'm playing...
WHAT?
Who's controlling this bitch?
Oh what is, why is it
Why is the camera
momentum based?
Why? Why would the camera be MOMENTUM based?
That's-
That's asinine
Th - that's absurd
*stuttering* that's STUPID
Ok, so
this - STOP
Are you serious
Is this what I have to deal with? OH my god, I'm going to lose my goddamn -
FUCK YOU
I don't - NO GO AWAY! Purple!
Oh no, Purple... No purple wasn't me!
THIS CONTROLLS THE CAMERA AND THE *indistinct* ROTATION?
WHAT THE FUCK?
Why would it control the camera AND the rotation of the object? This is fucking stupid. I'm playing the-
OHHHHH
*grunts*
Okay, put it together.
Uh, FUCK! AHHHH
Try this again, ugh, ugh FUCK
AH HAH GODDAMN IT
WHY?
WHO DID THIS?
WHO THE FUCK DID THIS? WHO MADE THIS GODDAMN GAME?
I haven't even gotten ONE PEG IN!
IS THIS HOW THIS IS SUPPOSED TO GO?
I've never seen like, a video of this. This can't be right, something is very wrong.
Obviously. Okay, go on your side.
Ok, so I'm gonna pick you up while I'm-
Why, why is my mouse drifting down?
NO FUCK YOU
OH my GOD!
Ok, here we go
Fuck
*grunts* fucking- you're gonna *AHHHHHHH*
NO NOT YET NOT THAT ONE *starts screaming*
OOH I WAS GONNA TRY TO PUT IN THE -- FUCKING FUCK
I was trying to pick up the other one - Oh, it's upside down now, okay, fuck off.
Let's get one, one, in, in, in, in in in
LET IT GO. DID IT GO?
ahhhhHHHHHHHH FUCK OFF!
This cannot be right.
WHY AM I SLIDING?
Fucking fuck!
You! FUCK!
WHERE'D IT GO? I'M PRESSING BUTTONS. WH- THERE IT IS!
Fucking thank, oh it's still deciding to - ohh
in-in-in-in-in-in-in-in-in-in-in-in-in-
NOOOOOO *classical piano music starts to play*
You're music selection is not helping.
*heavy breathing*
Well it's the WRONG way.
Just, just go in!
In!
IN! JUST GO IN! It was gonna go in!
It was gONNA GO INNNN!
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO MAKE IT GO IN!
I DON'T KNOW!
How the fuck?
OH FUCK OFF! FUCK YOU!
This isn't right! Right? I should just fucking restart it!
Good god.
What the fuuuUUUCK?
Okay, I just gotta calm down because, fuck, I'm gonna burst a blood vessel in my brain and I'm gonna die.
Okay, so obviously something is not right.
Options.
Game play.
THAT'S NOT GAME PLAY!
*whining*
Oh, so pissed.
*even more whining*
It's right there!
What am I doing wrong? I don't know. I don't know!
How do I know what to do? I don't!
OH FUCK! God-
Where'd it go? Where'd it go again? Where the fuck did it go? Where the FuCK did it go?
I don't know where the level is now. I don't know where the level is!
I can't get one. I cannot get ONE peg. I can't get one f - OH THERE YOU ARE.
What the fuck is thAAAT.
What's happening? Good bye!
Oh hello!
I can't slow it down. What the - What the- that's not my- that's not my house!
There it is, there it is. I was upside down. Oh good, I'm still holding on to this piece of shit.
Okay, so I'm gonna switch back.. to the goddamn game pad.
We're gonna do this honky-wonky style.
Oh, oh now it just wants to give me the gamepad. Oh. Oh I see.
Oh that's so nice. Oh, oh that's so nice!
Oh it's finally nice to me.
Oh my god. Nyyoh my god
*weird throat noises* No, that ain't it.
That ain't it at all.
*noises* AHHH!
There! I GOT ONE! As much as I'd like to end it at one leg,
I KNOW I WOULDN'T BE FORGIVEN!!
Now, let's do this one too.
Badaboopie, I don't give a fuck if it's off, I don't give a flyinn' fuck.
I don't give a flying fuck!
Oh that's so nice. Oh that's so nice!
It work! It do work! It work!
Oh it work! OH! No, I don't want another box. I just got this one done.
There we go.
*cries*
Oh god I touched it. No I don't want two players!
God dammit just stop movin'
Stop movin' stop movin' stop mo-
Okay.
Up, you shall rise.
Okay
Well that didn't work
Is that how that's supposed to work?
I don't know
I DON'T KNOW
Okay, hang on. Wait. wait. wait
Ah! Ah.
Oh, okay. Oh, I did it wrong.
Ah fucking shit.
Ah! Oh, oh, ah.
Yes!
No! But, also yes!
YES!
YES!!!
Hang on.
I saw the dotted li- there we go
*man speaks Swedish*
*sighs*
I thought this was gonna be a game where you know
You go "Hah, aw man."
"I can't get it but it looks funny, am I right?"
My god.
What the f-
No I don't- I wanted to go to the garage!
I don't know how to zoom out.
*inhales*
Fucking get out of here just
LEAVE! NO ONE WANTS YOU HERE!
Alright fine
Oh man
I don't know. I was actually-
When I came in to this game I was ready to actually try.
I was ready to actually make a thing like
"Oh I- I know probably most people just dick around, but I'm gonna try to actually do it!"
FUCK
I don't know what these pieces are.
I don't know where they go.
I don't know anything about this.
This became a lot less fun when I discovered that it hates me.
When I discovered that everything in the universe hates me!
That's when I stopped having fun.
*sarcastic laughter*
Get the fuck outta here
Get da fuck outta- I don't wanna see ya!
Get outta here. You too pillar.
You too curshern
You also other cushion
*pretends to be the cushion* "But I wasn't doing anything!"
SHUT UP! You're the same as them.
Supposed to be a bench right?
Yeah *attempts to speak Swedish*
*tries again*
*is actually just making up words*
*contines babbling*
Ah! I know- I know what that is. Okay. I know.
Ah. I do know.
Okay I know, I know, I get it now. Okay.
So these have- yeah! Those have four connectors. Okay
So that's very important.
Okay, so you gotta be- yeah.
That's the stuff. Okay.
So yes.
This is a clue here as to-
Euuh
Yeah!
Okay.
Yeah, line up the shadow. Use the shadow as my guiding.
Boop.
YEAH
Okay!
Yes!
Okay! Alright, okay.
Return of the *trails off into mumbles*
Yeah! Yeah, yeah! Yeah, yeah! YEAH! YEAH!
I'm gonna build this shit!
I'm gonna build it!
Yeah! I'm gonna build it! It's gonna be great!
Just like that.
Okay, a little off.
I coulda done that better. Admittedly I coulda done that a lot better.
BAM
Okay! Alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay.
Alright okay!
Habooski
YE-
-ah. We're gettin' somewhere
We're gettin' somewhere good.
Or somewhere very not good.
I don't care which at this point, as long as we get somewhere.
Okay, I'm gettin' better at it.
Which is a scary thought.
But it's what's happening.
Huh
Yeah! Little off, but that's okay. The other ones are equally as little off.
Okay, so, then
What I'll- What I'll need to do is I'll need to put one of these on first.
Okay, there we go.
And then onto both of these.
I said both of those.
I said both of those young lady!
Eh, wah, eh, wah
HAH!
YEAH
Okay, so now this one doesn't need to do much of anything.
It just needs to go-
Oh
It needs to go alright.
It needs to go right in there.
Yeah! Okay, okay.
One more glorious piece!
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh god, is this gonna?
Is it gonna do properly?
Heh! *more Swedish man speaking*
YEAH!
OH YES!
I have a table!
I can't believe it.
I did it.
oh
No!
Don't you frickin' dare be douchey on me!
I am the one who douches.
boink
Oh
It-It's lovely.
It's a lovely
What was it called again?
A lovely-
Fuhquas- NO!
Get it outta here! I don't wanna do it!
I'm done!
Okay so that's all for Home Improvisation.
Now that I actually figured out the controls I know how to play and we don't need to visit this ever again
right guys??
Let me know what you think in the comments below and
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
I'm gonna go lay down and pet Chica and try to de-stress as best I can.
So thanks again, and as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*incomprehensible shouting and shooting*